miranda lambert debuted her new musical
music video
last night for her third single offer
album wild card and she went with
uh settling down and the video features
her actual husband of almost two years
brendan mclaughlin
who she met while he was an nypd officer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
going both directions
what was it like filming with brendan
and why did you choose him to have him
in your video
duh i think we understand why i had in
my video because he's very pretty
and uh i needed a video babe and he was
there so
i mean just worked out uh
where was he nervous to have his video
debut i think he was nervous he
he was a little nervous but he he he and
i would come find each other
in breaks and i'd be like okay and he he
was he did a really good job
i came up with this concept um because
of the lyrics of the song
i wanted to shoot something at my home
my farm
um preferably with my husband i just
felt like it was very intimate and
um you know kind of set up the lyrics so
we talked to trey fan joy our favorite
director
and friend and she sort of made it this
beautiful fairy tale but also very down
home and
down to earth and um it was shot at my
happy place with with my happy person so
it was a really good day
porsha says oh wow he's hot unless this
is her husband he is fine
faces i'm surprised this relationship
lasted come on faith have a little faith
oh come on come on uh
and and for a guy that just joined
instagram i think like a couple of days
ago did
he's had a hell of a week um i
i like this unless it's what i love
about country artists and what makes
country artists so different is that
their
entire lives are sort of open to the
fans but i think it's that the fans have
such great respect
in that trust that the artists put you
know it
with them that it makes it wonderful and
with the amanda blake story you know has
just been headline after headline after
headline
and i think that miranda needed this i
think that she needed to do it and you
know
like she said you know like the guy's
pretty and she needed a hunk for her
video
and you go to the ex-cop husband and and
why not but i find it interesting that
the majority of comments that i've been
seeing on facebook
uh that mention miranda's new video also
contain the word
upgrade which i find very honest
paulis is so glad she's in a happy place
i do find this interesting though
because her relationship with blake
was so public and yeah that very public
divorce and they almost flaunted their
relationship remember they used to
flaunt
the headlines that were saying that they
were gonna get divorced like they would
make fun of that and then so it all blew
up in her face
so it was understandable when this
relationship started that we didn't know
she was dating this brendan guy till
they got married that was the first time
we knew
they were even dating so i understood
why she kept it so private
and yeah she's put him on instagram and
stuff like that and some of her promo
stuff but obviously it's a whole other
level to put someone in your music video
and yeah i am surprised
that she's doing it because miranda does
seem even though she's a country artist
she does seem
very guarded a very private person so
but at the same time she also seems to
be the kind of person that doesn't
really care what people think so she's
gonna
put him in the video and that's that
yeah and i and and i i fully agree with
you which is
the i think the thing that i do find
interesting is
oftentimes you don't see people making
the same mistakes twice and and
the example that i'll bring up is ryan
reynolds
and ryan reynolds when he was with
alanis was very
open about their relationship and during
any interview
if you asked him anything about their
relationship he was cheeky and he was
fun
and a complete open book and then when
that ended ryan's relationships after
that he was very closed off
you know from them and so what's
interesting is to see somebody go down
the same road twice
with being just so sort of open in
public right i will say about this song
too so i'm a big fan of miranda and this
song's settling down
it's funny this song doesn't strike me
as the most romantic song because the
whole idea of
playing on that phrase of settling down
right like am i am i
settling like am i settling up or am i
settling down because she's such a
drifter
and wants to be out on the road like you
know getting married and having a home
is this me like downgrading myself so i
never really saw this song as a romantic
song
it's funny that she sees it as a
romantic song and made this super
romantic video it's just funny when i
hear this song i don't see it
it's like questioning whether or not
should i have done this
should i yeah yeah yeah that's always
the most romantic thing